لقد كان التدريب دائمًا أمرًا مهمًا للغاية على ما أعتقد
وهو أمر أكثر أهمية الآن ونحن نقوم بحلقة من
زيادة الاستعداد القتالي في لبنان لدينا الكثير
وقد تعلم الكثير منهم الكثير من القتال في غزة
إنها ذات صلة كبيرة بالقتال في لبنان، وهناك بعضها
التي يجب أن تمر بالتعديل الذي نريد الوصول إليه
في لبنان لغرض واضح جداً هو إعادة
وسكان الشمال هم جميع المستوطنات في الشمال
افهم أن هذا الشيء يجب أن يمر بالتغيير
مهم جداً لا أعلم متى الحرب
في الشمال، أستطيع أن أقول لك أن احتمال حدوث ذلك
وما سيحدث في الأشهر المقبلة هو أكثر من ذلك بكثير
أعلى مما كانت عليه في الماضي، أستطيع أن أقول لك
أعتقد أننا نبدأها بالكثير
المزيد من الفوائد انتصار الثقة معنا
الثقة تقل مع كثرة الخبرة والقدرات
المفاجآت تنتج من التقدم ما تم تحقيقه وما بقي
تدريب روح قوية على محمل الجد من الناس وعازف الكمان
سوف نتقدم في كل شيء
القوة